Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 video a lot of you
requested that i make a video about the big rumor
of tobey maguire and andrew garfield coming back
for spider-man 3 so i'll explain what's going on
what's being reported and what sony and marvel
have said about it if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
but just starting with the big stuff first
number five a blogger was reporting inside
sources had told him that sony was negotiating
with both toby maguire and andrew garfield
themselves to come back for spider-man
3 with tom holland for big cameo scenes
blogs everywhere picked it up you probably saw
it all over the internet all over social media
all the headlines reading live-action spider-verse
confirmed etc etc so sony's official statement on
the matter last night was simply those reports
are not confirmed they didn't have anything else
to say about it marvel just started filming
spider-man 3 this week with tom holland which
is why you're seeing so much more spider-man
news right now marvel on the other side of this
rumor typically never responds to rumors of any
kind if you saw big websites reporting rumors of
robert downey jr coming back as iron man in the
black widow movie marvel wouldn't say anything
about it their default is to not respond at all
usually that winds up being better because when
sony comes out and says live-action spider-verse
andrew garfield toby mcguire coming back isn't
confirmed yet they're also kind of acknowledging
that it might be a thing but they maybe just
haven't finished the contracts yet because
spoiler am i not supposed to have what i want
what i need number four tom holland himself
hasn't spent a ton of time working with either
toby maguire or andrew garfield before but he has
spoken to them in the past and had a lot of really
nice things to say about them with respect to the
spider-man of it all these are the clips of him
explaining his meetings with both of them andrew
was so lovely we had a really good chat together i
met toby very briefly but they're both nice guys
he's a really really great actor i don't know
if you've seen his work he was in this movie the
impossible and he's just this incredibly powerful
sensitive just wonderful young actor and
a dancer so his his body is the right
i'm just really excited to just be a fan again
as opposed to bearing the weight of it so like
he said he grew up watching the tobey maguire
spider-man movies as a kid just like everybody
else he's also a big fan of andrew garfield's work
not just his spider-man movies toby maguire hasn't
been that active in terms of acting roles in the
last couple of years but he is still working on
his own separate projects behind the scenes and
because now we have sam raimi coming back to do
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness and they're
filming that movie at the same time as they're
filming spider-man 3. doctor strange was confirmed
as a crossover character for spider-man 3
the idea now is that there will be some sort of
live-action spider-verse elements in spider-man 3
that does seem more plausible if all these things
are all happening at the same time the way they're
talking about doctor strange and spider-man 3 is
that he's going to become a mentor for spider-man
at least temporarily in the way that iron man was
his mentor before he died so think about how much
iron man was in spider-man homecoming and that's
probably about how much we'll see doctor strange
during spider-man 3. people always make jokes
about iron man taking over spider-man homecoming
like the movie was really iron man homecoming but
when you think about it he actually was only in a
couple scenes of that movie just a little bit at
the beginning in the middle and then at the end so
spider-man 3 will still be very much a spider-man
story about him solving his problems he'll just
get a little bit of an assist from doctor strange
and then the doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness movie comes out right after spider-man 3.
so that's why also people are now thinking that
spider-man might also cameo during doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness the way that thor crossed
over with doctor strange in the post credit
scene then they did a much bigger version of
that crossover later in thor ragnarok marvel's
also kind of doing the same thing with thor 4
love and thunder and guardians of the galaxy
3. where you have the guardians showing up at
the beginning of thor 4 to address what happened
at the end of avengers end game then supposedly
according to vin diesel thor is supposed to
show up in guardians of the galaxy 3 in some way
thor will also the director talk to me about how
thor will incorporate some of the guardians of the
galaxy which would be very interesting nobody
knows but maybe i shouldn't have said anything
so even though the operating term of marvel
phase four is multiverse starting with all the
Wandavision stuff that we're gonna see later this
year big crossovers also seem like they're gonna
be par for the course during marvel phase four
number three toby mcguire and andrew garfield
already almost came back as their versions of
spider-man for the animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie tom holland almost also had a
cameo in that too as his version of mcu spider-man
because they were trying to incorporate more
live-action elements into the crossover stuff
when they were still pitching the movie to sony
lord and miller said that they wanted to go full
spider-verse in the truest sense of the word as
crazy as possible with all the different versions
of the characters but sony executives said that at
the time they felt like it was too soon to bring
andrew garfield and toby mcguire back at the same
time when i heard that my assumption was is they
just try to do a version of that scene during
spider-man into the spider-verse 2. they're in
the middle of making that movie right now it's
supposed to come out in 2022. i know there's
all this focus on live-action spider-verse stuff
but they're still doing the animated spider-verse
2 in a couple years then around the time that
they were doing the press tour for spider-man
far from home a couple years ago amy pascal said
that the studio was also considering doing legit
live-action spider-man into the spider-verse
crossing over andrew garfield and toby maguire
but at the time and remember this is a couple
of years ago it was just an idea they weren't
actively making that movie yet most of their
big crossover attention at that time and
currently now is still focused on crossing over
spider-man with the venom characters sony's also
still trying to create more spin-offs with the
spider-man characters it controls no joke because
of the way the spider-man movie rights work they
have access to over 900 different characters so
you can believe that they want more spin-offs but
then we found out about them bringing back jamie
foxx's electro for spider-man 3. so number two the
thing about jamie foxx coming back is that when
you look at some of his instagram posts after
they made the announcement a couple weeks ago
he says he's not going to be blue this time but
he also posted a bunch of spider-verse pictures
that really complicates things because normally
the thing about him not being blue electro again
would just mean that the version of electro
he's playing won't be the same electro from
the amazing spider-man 2 movie he'd show up
looking different because he was mcu electro with
a different backstory it was a little more comic
book accurate in a costume that was a little more
like classic electro's costume just because that
sort of mcu operating procedure make it look like
the classic comic book version but sort of update
their backstory so that it makes sense within the
context of the mcu movies that have happened so
far in the ending of avengers end game that's why
a lot of people were making iron man jokes about
the new electro being another disgruntled former
employee of tony stark just like mysterio and you
do joke but in the comics electro did used to work
for stark industries so it is technically
accurate to the classic spider-man comics
as you would expect the marvel snipers got to
him he almost immediately deleted his post after
making it but the spider-verse pictures he posted
also kind of make you wonder if he was pitched a
version of a multiverse story sometimes details
like that can change during the making of movies
from the time actors get pitched on coming back
like here's what we're thinking for your character
we bring him back and this is what the story is
then by the time they actually get ready to film
the movie the script has already changed a couple
times so those details wind up changing as well
if he's not going to be the multiverse electro
from the amazing spider-man movies then it's
more likely that they have just some references
and easter eggs to amazing spider-man 2 in the
stuff that he did during that movie just as a fun
wink to that so number one the likelihood of them
actually bringing back toby maguire and andrew
garfield both in spider-man 3 in addition to all
the sinister six stuff that they're already
doing through the venom movies like venom 2
the morbius movie with michael keaton's
vulture character crossing over between
different sony and marvel movies it just seems
really unlikely that they would try to stuff
so much huge stuff into spider-man 3. marvel
does not need to roll that hard on spider-man 3.
sony has already said that they want to make
spider-man 4 with marvel so they have plenty of
room to do more live-action spider-verse if they
really do want to go that far so my expectations
right now for spider-man 3 is that yes there
will be some multiverse elements because of the
doctor strange of it all in the<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>
reality warping from the<span style="font-size: 18.7px;">Wandavision</span>series
cannot wait to watch her just completely mess with
the mcu multiverse but i think it's more likely
that they would just include easter eggs for the
other versions of spider-man when they're teasing
multiverse crazy elements and we won't actually
see andrew garfield's face or tobey maguire's face
on screen really good example of this is
something like that toby maguire spider-man
suit that showed up in the morbius trailer
freaking everyone out there's still thousands
of questions about what that's supposed to mean
most people believe that it's actually just a
placeholder for tom holland's mcu spider-man
suit because it has been confirmed by both kevin
feige and the sony people that spider-man will
eventually cross over with the venom characters
so you could say that they're already kind of
doing some live-action spider-verse in a sense
but until marvel and sony release spider-man 3
venom 2 in the morbius movies it's too soon to
tell exactly how they're going to explain the
logic of those crossovers i think a lot of this
just depends on how crazy you think the plot of
spider-man 3 is going to be so just take all these
big rumors with a grain of salt remember they're
filming spider-man 3 in doctor strange 2 right now
so there's going to be a lot of this stuff flying
around in the news for the next couple of months
i'll try to do as many videos as i can depending
on what i think is true or what is not true leave
all your requests in the comments below if you
have any big questions about what's going on
but click here for the boys season 3 trailer and
click here for my full spider-man 3 electro video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!